Alice how many handicapped people do we
have in this office that a trick
question we have what one woman took
like that too
alas there are but two handicap parking
spots which is arithmetic m'lady yeah
you do the math Alice what they're
trying to say is that there's no spots
out there for normal people like us all
right so I'm out there parked on the
street and what I'm supposed to let move
my car two hours is student real act
real Alice cuz guess what we're here
every day at ten o'clock
okay maybe 1002 but when we get here the
parking lots all packed out mer Sol so
why don't you just scratch our butts a
little bit and give us the bonus
handicapped parking spot okay first of
all work starts at 9:00 yeah and see
this this is me making a note of giving
you that spot oh it parking spot two
idiots change tampon yourself change
stamp on grody
that's not funny don't kill yourself hey
onder's what hang on if you're parked on
the street there's a guy out there
writing tickets Lucy great
you